what's up guys today we're going to be
taking a look at the best start anova
l-shaped desk which can also be a
u-shape desk if you guys buy on the add
on in this video I'm only going to be
concentrating on the l-shaped portion I
will be making a dedicated video about
the 4 you should portion and the add-on
portion so if you guys are interested in
that then make sure to click the link in
the description below I don't want to
waste your time so let's jump right in
starting off this desk is on the bigger
side of desks it measures in at 59 point
8 inches by 59 inches it's right about 5
feet by 5 feet and it is sixty six point
four inches tall the hot side has a
usable desk depth of eighteen inches and
the other side has usable dust space
depth of nineteen point seven five
inches at the deepest portions and it
measures in as sixteen inches at the
shallowest regions it comes with the
hutch as for small storage shares which
each measure in at fourteen point two
five inches by three point one two five
inches on top of that there are four
larger storage areas and two of them
have a door these compartments measure
in at fourteen point two five inches by
12.5 inches there are also two drawers
on the hot side both drawers measure in
at 12 by 15 inches and the bottom drawer
does have a lock and comes with two keys
two drawers have ball bearing slides
which make the sliding smooth and quite
the maximum height that you guys can
store underneath the hutch with the top
bar is anything up to sixteen point
seven five inches without the top bar
you guys can store an extra two inches
or a total of eighteen point seven five
inches there is a sliding keyboard
holding crate which measures in at
twenty seven inches by fourteen point
seven five inches and allows for maximum
clearance of 2.75 inches from the ground
you get thirteen point two five inches
of clearance under the drawers and you
guys get twenty seven inches of
clearance underneath the desk itself ask
for the surface the surface is a
commercial grade work surface with the
melamine finish that resists scratches
stains and wear however unfortunately
smudges are clearly visible on the
surface but it is easily cleanable it is
still annoying to do
the desk you guys are seeing right here
is in the color Tuscany brown and black
there is another color option available
as well which is called Antigua it has a
grayish colored surface with a brushed
like design on the surface and the hutch
supports and drawers are all white asked
for assembly this desk is very annoying
and takes many many hours for me it took
over eight hours to fully assemble just
the l-shaped portion of the desk but I
was working alone and wasn't too keen on
finishing it quickly if you guys like
building stuff like me then assembling
it is not gonna be that bad and it feels
rewarding when you're completely done
building however if you guys don't enjoy
building and just want the function desk
provides then it is going to be very
annoying for you plus something that
makes it even worse is that all the
parts in this desk are very heavy so
it's very hard to be able to move around
and assemble however once you are done
is very sturdy and it can support a lot
of weight finally I have the hutch on
the left side but since the desk
is reversible you can have the hutch
portion on the right side as well now
let's talk about some areas that this
desk is lacking first of all while the
desk looks great the materials aren't
the absolute best the wood is particle
board and the plastic isn't the best
either also this desk was built a big
computer desk which can be seen in this
slide out tray on the bow shaped front
this makes this great for people using
their desk for the computers but for
people who want to do physical work
which includes a lot of papers or
requires a lot of desk space for things
like drawing or creating posters or
other big things this is not that great
because there's not much space to put a
lot of paper also the underneath portion
of the desk is not in the same nice wood
finish as a top it's just plain white
finally some portions of the desk aren't
perfectly aligned like the drawer but
those are pretty much the only issues
with this desk that's about it for all
the features and negative this desk now
let's talk about the price you guys can
get this desk on Amazon right now for
right under $500 and there's free
shipping this free shipping is
actually not bad at all it is actual
excellent the shipping company calls you
the day before and it's very flexible
and nice however you keep in mind the
day will not put this inside your house
but that's against their policy so they
will only come as far as the door
there's experts simply available but
that cost about a third of the desk
itself so I just recommend that you guys
just do it yourself
maybe with a friend so as you can see
this desk is quite great and offers a
lot of space for computer users and
gives much more premium look
dudas would like look combined with the
hutch while being at a price that is
quite reasonable as well as a result
should you buy this the answer to that
question is very simple if you guys are
looking for an l-shaped desk for your
computer that has a hutch has a nice
finish and good construction well not
the best and it's not crazy expensive
like some other L chef's desk and you
guys should definitely get this it'll
serve your purpose very well and you
will definitely be satisfied for many
years
you guys should even consider that you
shipped add-on for this desk because it
gives you a lot more space for not not
much more money however if you guys are
looking for their most premium desk with
the best materials or if you guys are
okay with the cheaper desk that doesn't
look as good or have as good materials
but performs the same function like
cheap IKEA desk you guys should still
consider this please this is right in
the middle and offers the best value out
there so while it's not the best it'll
save you a lot of money and it's a lot
better than cheaper desks and if you
guys are looking for a cheaper desk then
this is just so much better for not much
more money so you guys should consider
this as well overall in my opinion this
is the best value l-shaped desk in the
market and if you guys are looking for
value then you guys should definitely
buy this but if you crave quality or
just don't want to spend this much money
on a desk then you guys should look
elsewhere well guys that's all I have
about this desk make sure to check out
my review on the u-shaped add-on if you
guys are interested in buying this if
you have any questions to make sure to
comment them down in the comment section
below
I read all my comments so I'll make sure
to answer them to my best ability well
guys that's all I have for you guys this
time if you guys like this video then
make sure to give me a like if you guys
loved it and liked
more videos just like this then make
sure to hit the subscribe button and hit
the bell notifications then you guys
notify every time that I post a new
video well guys that's all I have for
you today and until next video bye